the green new deal the green new deal is
not the law
the green new deal hasn't been passed uh
in the house and senate and signed by
the president the green new deal
isn't policy anywhere and yet
republicans more and more are blaming
the green new deal
for the power failure in texas that we
saw over the last
week to 10 days how is this possible
this would be like blaming medicare for
all for a problem
when medicare for all isn't the law in
the united states
here is an example cancun cruz a
republican texas senator ted cruz who
recently
fled over the u.s mexico border with his
family to mexico when the power went out
at his house in texas
only to come back 20 hours later after
his escape attempt blew
up in his face he was on sean hannity's
fox news program last night
saying that what is to blame for the
power outages in texas
is the green new deal take a look
we just came off of a very difficult
week where the grid
failed four million texans and so we
need to have a serious examination
about why that was why the grid came
short
but one of the major elements of that is
actually the policy that schumer is
pushing for the whole country
which is the green new deal you look at
texas right now about 25
of our electricity capacity is wind and
yet
in the middle of this storm that
capacity dropped all the way down to
two percent you want to talk about
reliability the the reality was in the
cold the wind turbines froze
and and the power generation wasn't
there ted cruz manages to squeeze
about six lies into that
short 40-second segment that i played
for you
it's a great um illustration of the
problem we're talking about so let's
talk through it
first of all what texas did over the
last
10 15 years with their power grid it's
nothing like what the green new deal
would do
ted cruz wants you to believe that
texas went all in on green energy and
now has power failures and it's a
preview of what happens
to the whole country if the whole
country goes in the direction of green
energy
texas did something that's the opposite
of the green new deal
texas isolated their power grid from the
rest of the country
to avoid so-called federal government
meddling and interference in their
energy market
former governor rick perry talked about
it last week we've heard from a number
of different people
bragging about we are an independent
grid
the green new deal doesn't call for that
and so what happened was that when the
grid was
stressed and we'll talk about why it was
stressed they couldn't get power from
anywhere else it has nothing to do with
what is in the green new deal and of
course
the green new deal hasn't passed second
ted says
wind energy is 25 of power generation
capacity in texas
this is in theory accurate texas can
in theory get up to 24.8 percent of
power from wind
but that's seasonal in the winter it's
only a fraction of that
last week when the power outages
happened 25
of actual electricity was not coming
from wind power but
more importantly third when ted says
that energy generation capacity from
wind plummeted during the storm
that's true but it also plummeted even
more
for natural gas coal and nuclear on
which texas is significantly more
reliant
and the reason is not because of wind
power versus nuclear versus coal or gas
it's because texas chose not to
winterize
any of their power generation so they've
got an isolated grid
that can't up pull from any other part
of the country
and they opt not to winterize as i've
said a dozen times in the last week
back in 2011 texas had similar outages a
report was compiled explaining
how you prevent this in the future and
they just didn't do it and yes
some wind farms froze because they
weren't winterized
but the bigger problem was frozen
instruments at
coal natural gas and nuclear power
plants
which are not winterized everything ted
cruz is saying is a lie
now you might see this and write it off
and say
david how can the green new deal be to
blame for anything it hasn't been passed
it hasn't been made law no one would
fall for this
and yet they do just look at twitter
look at reddit look at the
quote debates happening on cable news
right now this stuff works
on lots of republicans when obamacare
was being debated
before it passed there were republicans
blaming obamacare for not being able to
get medical procedures wasn't the law
yet
protesters doing things last summer
were being blamed on this is biden's
america
trump was president millions of them
fell for it and this is sort of part of
how they blamed antifa
for the january sixth insurrection
incited by trump
carried out by trumpists antifa had
nothing to do with it
so unless time travel is a factor
that i somehow don't understand and that
we've not yet been able to explain and
what we're talking about is
time moves in a different way than we
conceive of it there is no possible way
that the green new deal is responsible
but it doesn't matter to them
they are either falling for it or
knowingly accepting something that's
untrue
in order to try to point fingers
elsewhere it's disgusting
but it represents a barrier
in actually getting things done properly
winterizing
these uh electrical grids and continuing
to move to green energy which in many
ways
is actually more robust in its ability
to resist
changes in climate and weather uh i
don't know what the future is
of this talking point but my instinct is
that it's going to be around for a while
and if and when joe biden actually gets
around to moving forward on his green
new deal infrastructure
green infrastructure plan rather which
takes elements from the green new deal
i would assume that many of these
republicans are going to fight it by
saying
green new deal type stuff is responsible
for what happened in texas in 2021 it'll
be untrue of course
but it's clearly a talking point they're
going to repeat and repeat and repeat
let me know what you think i'm on
twitter at d pacman
i want to take a second to tell you
about one of our sponsors
snh masks snh masks has
everything you need when it comes to
face masks and other protective gear
for covid19 and they're giving my
audience 20
off snh masks is the company that i've
personally been going to
for face masks i love and trust the
products they
sell and that's actually why i reached
out to them about being a sponsor i've
tried
tons of different face masks this year
like many of you
and i still have not found a mask that
is more comfortable
or easier to breathe in than the
washable cotton masks that they sell
it's made of a silky lightweight cloth
that feels great on the skin
has a convenient adjustable strap they
also have disposable cloth masks which
are really comfortable
as well as all of the other gear like
face shields alcohol wipes no touch
infrared thermometers and all of their
prices are
very reasonable i also love snh masks
because they've donated over 60 000
masks to healthcare
institutions they're an excellent
company shipping is just five bucks and
shipping
is free on orders over 150 dollars you
can get there by going to
davidpakman.com
mask the link is under this video and
you can save twenty percent on
everything in their store
when you use the coupon code david